مستشفى الرشاد التدريبي للامراض النفسيه
والعقليه في الرصافه في بغداد حديث
العراقيين على المنصات والسبب صور انتشرت
للمستشفى عملت حاله من الغضب الواسع
الصور اللي شفناها مع بعض قيل انها
لمستشفى الرشاد التدريبي للامراض النفسيه
والعقليه في بغداد اللي تاسس عام 1950
وحقيقه واضح انه من وقتها من عمل لتجديد
او تحسين لمرافقه فاللي بيشوف الصور
مستحيل يتخيل انه ممكن يكون هذا المكان
للرعايه الصحيه والنفسيه لانه بيفتقد
لابسط
مستلزمات الرعايه والناس صارت تقول المريض
النفسي اللي تعبان وجاي علشان يتعالج
ويتاهل نفسيا راح تسوق حالته اصلا يعني لا
نظافه ولا مرافق ولا شيء ومن سنوات
العراقيين بيتكلموا عن معاناه المستشفى من
قله الكوادر الطبيه والخدمات والعلاجات
والمستلزمات المطلوبه للحالات اللي
بيستقبلها لو كان عضو مجلس النواب السابق
رعد الماس كمان وصف المستشفى انه مقبره
للاحياء بس يبدو انه على الرغم من انه مرت
سنوات على هذا الكلام بس وضع المستشفى لسه
مثل ما هو ويمكن صار اسوا والعراقيين
نزلوا على المنصات تعبير عن استياء وغضب
من اللي شافوه
الفكره المستشفى هذه كان زارا من عشره
ايام بالتحديد مدير صحه الرصافه ورافقوا
كمان مستشار الصحه النفسيه في وزاره الصحه
وعملوا جوله في المستشفى وتفقدوا الخدمات
المقدمه واثنوا على جهود المدير العام
للمستشفى كمان والعاملين فيها